hey everyone is fair with registered
nurse orient comb and in this video I
want to go over how to use an ad on an
infant in my previous videos I went over
how to use an ad on an adult and in this
video I want to demonstrate how you
would do that on an infant however
before we begin I want to go over some
key concepts with you now the most
preferred method to defibrillate an
infant is to use a manual defibrillator
but sometimes that's not always the case
you don't always have the luxury of
having that with you and if you're out
in a setting the only thing you may have
is an AED so it's a very good idea that
you get comfortable with the type of
equipment that is around to because
every ad is set up a little bit
differently now it's recommended that
whenever you use an ad on an infant that
you use an ad with a pediatric
attenuator meaning that whenever you
shock that infant that it will deliver a
pediatric dose to the infant and also
you use pediatric pads and let me show
you the difference here right here we
have some pediatric pads they are
smaller than the adult pads these pads
can be used for a child and an infant
now compare these with the adult pads
they are a lot larger however say that
there's a situation you get an ad and
the only thing that is available for you
to use our adult pads and it does not
have your ad does not have a pediatric
attenuator so you can give an adult dose
to the infant using adult pads the key
is just not to overlap the pads make
sure that they're not touching now how
can you tell if an ad has a pediatric
attenuator again you want to get
comfortable with your equipment and make
sure you know how it works but generally
they'll have like a little key switch
that's similar
to what this looks like and it's
typically sometimes it's pink may look
like a little teddy bear and just to
signify to you that it's a pediatric
dose and then some ATS have little
switches on them where you could switch
it over so let me demonstrate for you
how to place the pads and how to use the
ad whenever you're using it on an infant
okay immediately whenever the AED
arrives you want to use it so you will
turn it on very first thing you'll do is
turn it on and it will tell you
everything to do and you'll want to
start getting your pads out and expose
their tests and get out the pediatric
pads if it has it and the pads will tell
you where to fit chapathi because this
is an infant we're going to put a pad on
the front and then we're going to put a
pad on the back so let's do that you're
going to put on the front and press it
down firmly and then as you turn the
infant over support their neck and flip
them over and then put it on their back
and then put them over again and you're
going to plug your connector into your
AED and analyze them and do not touch
the patient while analyzing because it
could cause it to read something that
doesn't have shock it by so what we're
going to do is make sure everyone's
leers and clear and whenever everyone's
clear you're going to hit the shock
button which is blinking and clear and
then you're going to start your CPR bag
and you'll do five cycles and after five
cycles this machine will read analyze
and see if we need another shock and
that beeping you're hearing is just
telling you the write that you need to
go because we need to go hard and fast
so that is
when you use an ad on an infant thank
you so much for watching this video and
be sure to check out my other CPR
teaching tutorials so you'll be prepared
for your CPR certification or
recertification class and a playlist
should be popping up so you can access
those videos and don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel